good afternoon
everyone my name is dr miller
and the scp we're going to be looking at
today is
scp-1459
object class safe
special containment procedures scp-1459
is to be kept within a standard
containment vault in safewing c
of sector 25. as of may 16
2000 only level 1 maintenance technician
valera may
view and interact with scp-1459
mt valor is to be presented with the
opportunity to receive a mild amnestic
to ameliorate emotional escalation
between testing sessions
in the event that mt valor becomes
unavailable to perform further tests
a new individual is to be selected by
the presiding on-site counselor
by executive order testing is to
continue
indefinitely description
scp-1459 is a modified claw crane arcade
game machine
that stands 2.3 by 1.2 by 1.5 meters
like most machines of this variety it
has a central rectangular space with
three clear walls on its front and
sides with a white plastic floor and
back
however scp-1459 is unique
in that the inner chamber has no shoot
where a prize would normally be
dispensed
the front panel features two coin slots
a large red button
a microphone a digital numeric display
a sign that reads when a cookie and a
thin horizontal slot from which the
aforementioned baked goods
are dispensed there is no power cord
attached to the back of the machine
nor is one needed as it is presumably
powered via anomalous means
when scp-1459 is inactive the central
chamber is completely bare
scp-1459 cannot be forcefully opened or
damaged by any known means
when one-quarter dollar coin is
deposited into scp-1459
a hatch will open in the ceiling of the
central chamber and a claw
carrying an instance of scp-14591
will descend from it scp-1459-1 and
other materials produced by scp-1459
are often too large to normally fit in
the upper section of the machine
it is unknown if these materials are
manifested by scp-1459 at the beginning
of the game sessions
or if they are teleported from another
location
after depositing the instance of
scp-14591
the digital numeric display will present
the number of games that have been
played previously
and a voice recording will play urging
the player to press the button
and describe oascp scp-1459-1
can be destroyed after this message has
been played
the button on the front panel will glow
and the numeric display will initiate a
15 second
countdown the player may then press the
button and dictate into the microphone
any
lethal action that can be performed upon
scp-1459-1
with the only restriction being that
players cannot choose a method
used in a previous game scp-1459-1 are
juvenile domestic
dogs canis lupus familiaris the breed
and gender of which
varies scp-1459 typically selects a
breed
that individual players holds the most
affection toward
aside from the seemingly infinite
quantity that scp-1459 contains
instances of scp-14591 do not appear to
display
any innate anomalous properties and
generally behave in a manner consistent
with animals of their variety
however scp-1459-1 instances may
occasionally be subjected to anomalous
changes to their physiology or behaviors
in order to facilitate the method of
destruction dictated by the player
if the player states a method of
extermination within the allotted 15
seconds
the hatch in the ceiling of the inner
chamber will open and an array of
mechanical arms
will descend carrying whatever is
necessary to carry out the player's
suggestion
requests for deaths that are not
possible within the confines of the
chamber will cause scp-1459 to display
additional anomalous properties to carry
out its orders
see experiment log once the instance of
scp-14591
is deceased one cookie will be dispensed
to the player via the slot in the front
of the machine
cookie flavors dispensed have included
chocolate vanilla
oatmeal raisin strawberry lemon
white chocolate and peanut butter the
exact variety dispensed to a given
player is often one that the player has
the lowest preference for
if the player fails to state a method of
extermination or the method proves
insufficient
a robotic arm will descend from
scp-1459's hatch and bludgeon the
scp-1459-1 instance
until it is deceased no cookie will be
dispensed following this event
scp-1459 automatically cleans its
interior chamber after every game
first an arm holding a broom descends
and sweeps the remains of scp-14591
into a trap door next scp-1459 wipes
down the surfaces of the chamber by
deploying arms equipped with flat rubber
implements
spray bottles containing a soapy
solution and white clean
towels while this process is taking
place
a recorded message will tell the player
yeah
you're totally going to hell for this
play again
experiment logs experiment one
player dr yeetly statement
stab it result scp-1459 played a sound
effect indicating the method of
extermination had been previously used
experiment number two player dr yeetly
statement chainsaw result
same as previous experiment superfluous
test logs redacted
experiment number 48 player dr yeahly
statement shark bite result
the hatch anomalously elongated and
produced a great white shark
carcredon carcharias which proceeded to
bite off scp-1459-1's head
and recede back into the machine
experiment number 49 player dr yeatley
statement running over result
scp-1459 produced a tire attached to a
spinning mechanism
after the mechanism accelerated to an
estimated 2000 rpm it made contact with
scp-14591
experiment 50 player dr yeatley
statement drop it from a great height
result scp-1459-1
fell through scp-1459's trapdoor
15 minutes later it fell through the top
hatch at high speed
and was instantly killed experiment 51
player dr yeetly statement
reality television result
a 1958 general electric television set
fell on scp-1459-1 then the set powered
on and replayed
the event experiment 52
player dr eatly statement death by
blender
result scp-1459 produced and lowered
scp-1459-1 into
brand blender scp-1459 sat
unharmed inside the device for three
minutes after which
a robotic arm pressed puree
the blender was uncovered when this
transpired
experiment 53 player dr
yeatley statement murdered by its lover
result scp-1459 produced a second
instance of scp-1459-1
which proceeded to claw and bite the
first instance
until it died of blood loss the second
instance was eliminated via scp-1459's
default bludgeoning method
note only one cookie was dispensed
experiment number 55 player dr yeatly
statement murder suicide result
as in the first test a second scp-1459-1
murdered the first
following this scp-1459 provided the
second scp-14591
with a hammer which the animal ran into
repeatedly
note two cookies were dispensed
experiment number 59 player dr yeetly
statement crime of passion
result the hatch elongated and a
caucasian woman in a red evening gown
emerged
the woman who has not yet been
identified strangled scp-14591 while
sobbing
and screaming the phrase you dog
repeatedly
the woman performed this action
continuously for 15 minutes
afterward both the woman and the
deceased scp-1450
fell through the trapdoor and out of
view
experiment number 57 player dr yeatley
statement drowning in puppies
result additional scp-14591 were
produced
until the entire chamber was filled to
capacity
the remaining space was filled with
water
god damn it note many cookies
were dispensed superfluous logs redacted
experiment number 231
player dr lavquest statement
civil war result
a man in a historically accurate uniform
of the confederate state's army circa
1863
dismembered scp-14591 with his bare
hands
experiment 232 player dr
siddl statement the judicial system
result 15 additional instances of
scp-1459-1 were produced
one of which wore a miniature powdered
wig and a black cloak
and two of which miniature suits
a noose was lowered around the first
instance head and hanged to the instance
the same procedure was applied to the
remaining 14 instances
note 15 cookies were dispensed
all of which were of the raise and
variety
experiment number 233 player
assistant researcher kirschner statement
made into cookies result
using kitchen implements and traditional
ingredients scp-14591 was dismembered
and incorporated into a batch of
chocolate chip cookies
scp-1459's internal heat increased to an
estimated 300 degrees celsius
scp-1459 then produced a caucasian woman
in a red evening gown
who consumed the cookies while smiling
wordlessly at assistant researcher
kirstner
note a chocolate chip cookie was
dispensed
no traces of animal matter detected in
its composition
experiment number 234 player
junior researcher leishman statement
falling off a roller coaster result
scp-1459's mechanical arms constructed a
miniature roller coaster within the
internal chamber
over the course of three hours once
completed
scp-1459-1 rode the ride normally
until the loop section at which point
the ride stopped causing scp-14591
to fall to the chamber floor scp-1459-1
was then bludgeoned via scp-1459's
default method
note no cookie was dispensed
experiment number 235 player
dr hoshi statement
batman result a concrete bust of the
fictional character was released from
the ceiling of the chamber
subsequently crushing scp-1459-1 the
floor
remained undamaged experiment number 236
player dr fillmore statement
knowledge of the unknowable result
an entity resembling o5 emerged from the
trapdoor of the inner chamber
picked up scp-1459-1 and pulled it out
of sight
note when questioned o5 denied any
involvement in the incident
experiment 237 player
d-5923 statement
my bare hands result
scp-1459-1 reacted as if being strangled
although no additional presence was
observed in the chamber
d-5923 reported feeling scp-1459-1's fur
on its hands
as it died experiment 238
player d-5923
statement spontaneous combustion
result scp-14591
underwent what appeared to be an
accelerated form of scp-81
for those of you who don't know that's
scp-81
the spontaneous combustion virus
experiment 239 player
d-5923 statement
nuclear detonation subject terminated
mid-sentence
result the resulting explosion was
completely contained by scp-1459
note d-class personnel no longer
permitted for testing maintenance
technician valera selected for further
testing due to low likelihood of k-class
scenarios
resulting from her requests note 2
368 cookies were dispensed in rapid
succession the significance of this
is unknown experiment 240
player maintenance technician valera
statement happy thoughts
result scp-14591 was injected with a
black substance
convulsed and collapsed
experiment 241 player
maintenance technician valera statement
love result a caucasian woman
in a red evening gown emerged from
scp-1459's upper chamber
sat on scp-1459-1's face and began
moaning in apparent pleasure after
continuing this activity for another
five hours
both individuals were removed from
scp-1459's claw
gross experiment number 242
player maintenance technician valera
statement old age result
scp-1459 played a sound effect
indicating that the method of
extermination had been previously used
maintenance technician valera was unable
to think of an alternative method of
extermination
and scp-14591 was disposed of
in the default manner experiment 243
player maintenance technician valera
statement please no kill dog
result scp-14591 was given a pillow
a treat and pat on the head by a gloved
mechanism
15 minutes later it was retrieved by
scp-1459's claw
immediately afterward scp-1459 produced
a juvenile domestic
feline felis katus and exterminated it
with a single blow to the head
with a sledgehammer note a salted
cracker
was dispensed
addendum the following is a
manufacturer's mark
present on the rear panel of scp-1459
brought to you by the good folks at ywtg
thft in partnership with sugar comb
confections
some anomalies just why
you know what i mean why
anyway thank you for listening if indeed
you still are
and you were all dismissed goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to bad luck lou
it's not a spoon arbiter soul
the morrigan james saba
nicola w joker corvus
kawaii fire keeper king madding
samurai corgis daniel
nj vujak justin day
and eric corbich if you would like a
special thank you at the end of each of
my videos
and some other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash the organ thank you
you